thanks Mason can I get a high five so
that's me and yep that's the yodeling
Walmart boy dabbing you're probably
wondering how I got here
hey guys it's Alan here at BuzzFeed New
York if you haven't seen in the past few
days this video of a boy at Ling and
Walmart has gone crazy viral people re
mixing it putting funny captions on it
it's hysterical and I'm obsessed with
this video
this boy is awesome at yodeling Walmart
just tweeted that Mason Ramsey the
yodeling Walmart boy is going to have a
live concert at the Walmart where the
video is special concert at Harrisburg
Walmart store can't wait to see the
concert is tomorrow and I have to go I'm
obsessed with this video a half ago I
need to go so tomorrow morning
I'm headed to Harrisburg Illinois to see
the yodeling Walmart boy performed live
at the Walmart all right you guys it's
6:45 in the morning on Wednesday April
11 today is the day that my dreams come
true have you heard of the the yodeling
Walmart boy the flight isn't too bad but
there's a drive afterwards
okay so we made it to st. Louis just
touchdown we have about a two and a half
hour drive to Harrisburg I'm here with
here with Dorothy he's alone for the
ride too
I need some high-quality yodeling today
from our boy we got the car don't know
much about Ella Noi don't know much
about Harrisburg but I can guarantee
there's some good live music at the
Walmart today we made it to Harrisburg
where you can really tell them the
community it's like after a full day of
travel we have officially made it to the
Walmart in Harrisburg Illinois the crowd
is out you guys Oh everyone's getting
these yellow Mason Ramsey t-shirts which
is amazing and about an hour Mason
Graham she's gonna come out on that
stage and yodel for us this is a true
dream come true okay we just got word
that DJ suede and is going to be
performing and if you're not familiar
with DJ's slavey he's the deejay that
remixed the Walmart yodel boy song this
is unreal my day just keeps getting
better and better
this way the remix guy when did you
first see the meet her first day that I
see Mason's video maybe about a week and
a half ago and then all of my followers
they blow me up beyond me and box me
like yo this way you got a remake [ __ ]
this kid is awesome and I did and I'm so
glad I did almost a million views on my
youtube so many followers I'm getting
some Mason bro isn't
the kid I get depends all the time but
this is just another level of this new
fans you know new
loving every second okay thanks do she
ate it yeah good luck out there
absolutely okay you guys I made it to
the stage this is right here where it's
informing look at this crowd this crowd
in Harrisburg is pretty pretty rowdy
pretty good yeah well so hi I'm John
McPhee the mayor of Harrisburg Illinois
and we're here from Mason Ramsey concert
here are fabulous Walmart in Harrisburg
and I'm going to do a proclamation
declaring Lindsey April 11 2008 deep
bass and Ramsey Day we're really proud
of Mason and his family but they've done
for our community okay I think Mason's
about to come out which I'm very excited
about
[Music]
[Applause]
Masek yeah how you doing buddy let me
ask you what does it feel like to be
right here with this crowd and
everywhere across the world now I love
it
ladies and gentlemen performing live in
the parking lot of Walmart in Harrisburg
Illinois put your hands together basin
Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
okay guys the show just ended it was
awesome Mason did a great job
but everyone's just standing around
waiting for him to come meet and greet
his fans I think we're gonna go get to
meet him and talk to him about how he
became the yodeling Walmart boy Mason
can you tell me how it felt to be
excited my fans
really help me thank you all for coming
and had a great turn you had a great
time too so what do you have to say to
all of the people who who know and love
you out in the world and who are
watching your videos and listening to
you thanks Mason can I get a high five
Mason just dab can we do one more time
okay hi I made my dreams come true I've
met may send the yodeling Walmart boy
it's been a long day but it's been a
great day this is awesome thanks Walmart
thanks and Mason you're freaking Stark
okay bye
[Music]